(upbeat music)
(audience claps)
- The show is almost over
but first let's do one last
story to give you a smile.
Hopefully this is What I'm Liking.
(ethereal music)
(audience claps)
Check out these pictures
y'all they look just
like old pinup posters, the red lipstick,
the innocent poses, the
waving American flags right?
Well, every one of the
women in those photos
is a military veteran modeling
to help raise money
for other vets in need.
It's all part of the
nonprofit pinups for vets.
And we have the founder
of the organization on the line right now.
So everybody say hi to Gina Elise, hi.
- Hi, Kelly.
- Oh, you look beautiful.
- I love that whole vibe.
Oh, it's so beautiful.
So tell us more about Pin-ups for Vets
and how it all got started.
- Yeah, so it was basically back in 2006,
there were a lot of stories in the news
about our troops coming back
from Iraq, needing medical care.
And I felt so strongly
that I wanted to do something to help out.
And I've always been a big fan
of World War II Pin Up Art.
So I took my love of that art
to create a fundraising Pin Up Calendar
that we could use to support
our veterans and troops today.
So we do everything from
a 50 state, military
and VA hospital tour, where
we actually take the calendars
into the hospitals to deliver
as gifts of appreciation
to buying rehab equipment
for veterans, hospitals.
To doing these morale, boosting
makeovers for military wives
and female veterans, to
shipping care packages
to troops around the world.
And we've been doing this for 16 years.
- Oh, that's amazing.
(audience claps)
Congratulations on all the success.
And you also say this is a lot
about female empowerment as well, right?
- Yes, yes.
Basically back in 2014, we
started getting inquiries
from female veterans to volunteer with us.
So I started taking them
into the VA hospitals with us
and the patients were
shocked that the ladies
standing next to me decked
out in 1940s, Pin Up outfits
were also veterans.
And so I decided to start
putting these incredible ladies
in the calendar.
A lot of times when we think of a veteran,
we might think of a man.
But there's such incredible women
that have stepped up to serve our country.
And so I like to think that
this is really kind of
shifting the perception
about what a veteran is.
In our 2022 calendar
we have a female black
Hawk helicopter pilot.
We have an army doctor.
And a lot of times the ladies tell me
that this has really helped
them to reclaim their femininity
after getting out of the military
and to embrace that
feminine side of themselves
that they had to put on the back burner.
(audience claps)
- Absolutely, thank you so much Gina,
At least I'm liking your
post right now, right?
(beeps)
- Thank you.
- And that's not all, y'all
our season long partner,
Pilot Pen makers of G2.
The go to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show.
They want to honor ultimate over achievers
just like you ma'am.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for $1000, how does that sound?
(audience cheers)
- Thank you so much, Kelly, thank you.
- Absolutely, absolutely thank you so much
for joining us today.